welcome to this video this is the second
part of my coverage of my tournament
that I played the GM event yeah the good
the bad and the ugly this is the bad
part the good part time you already have
seen yeah so this video is covering two
games and this is around three and round
for those two games round two was a very
uneventful draw against grandmaster
kumar off from the Ukraine this is a
very good grandmaster have been about
2,600 rated for at one point but
nowadays he's a coach and his son rating
has suffered a bit he's like 225 20 or
something and he basically offered me a
driver craft a couple of moves and my
strategy was to play this game safe so a
draw was ok so i took that draw and the
plan was after that drawing round two to
win rounds three and four against the
two lowest rated players in the event
and this is about this is this video and
both games shown now were played on the
same day this was a double round always
tricky yeah let's start with this him
the black came round three against
Powell open yo it's a player from
Portugal he's rated 2224 and he was by
far the lowest rated guy in the vent so
if you don't win this one it will be
difficult so it's not a bad play as
beating his fair share of gm's for
example as I'm saw beforehand yeah okay
he's some playing like that and I went
for the for the bogo my line and i had
seen before in the in the preparation
that he always plays Knight c3 which is
somewhat strange to be honest if you are
willing to play an Enzo basically why
don't you play Knight c3 on move 3 but
ok it's a it's his choice I'm going to
play c5 here he went to III and this was
to be expected he had played this before
again so we get the huebner variation of
the NIMS o-line that I know rather well
as I've written this book about it so to
be released I hope in april may be may
some publishers thing it's already
basically submitted okay 92 e five them
huebner variation always leads to a
closed position very complicated to
strategic battle he played night be
three now the move that i have faced a
number of times in blitz to be honest i
never understood what this move is all
about I think it's just not very much to
the point but the nature of the position
is that it is so closed it doesn't
matter very much the night only three
what it does it is it protects deform
but I'm never really threatening as like
to take this pawn as the position opens
up for white advantageously white might
as well play a move like that and I
really never want to grep hear this kind
of position is very promising for white
is got ya everything opened for for the
bishops well that's a pretty wrong
diagonal it's got everything open for
the bishop so I'm not threatening to
take but ok you can play not be three
it's not a bad move in itself it's just
not doing very much ok b6 let can also
play e father it's possible but I don't
mind this kind of situation yeah age six
is a good all around waiting movie for
Luke v8 rock b8 is a bit mysterious um
yeah my um experience and and and let's
say knowledge that our fur gathered
while writing the book is that it is
somewhat tricky sometimes for black to
make moves in this kind of position
where the tension in the center is not
resolved for example if i play move like
let's say queen e seven something to
connect rooks later the means d5 is a
bit annoying because my night really
wants to go to e7
not to be a door da yeah those squares
are not really great and want to retreat
to e7 if i play move like rook e8 again
he might do that and then I rather want
to have her look back on fh to play f5
or f4 and later now so it's a bit
difficult to make moves and the move
route be a doesn't move that it's often
quite useful you have this kind of ideas
and it's getting out of the diagonal
which is not relevant at the moment but
sometimes it is so what I'm doing is I'm
playing little awaiting moves that don't
commit to anything yeah and he's some
shuffling a bit and puts his look here
on the on the D 2 square yeah I am not
quite sure if this is leading to much he
can do that it's not a mistake or
anything but ultimately it it's not
doing doing a lot Queenie 7 yeah I had
played night e 72 jigs to g6 without d5
being played but this way I'm actually
able now to play Queen e7 and don't have
to misplace my night if he goes d5 yeah
went Queenie one this should be six rook
t1 yeah this he doubles on the D file
but yeah I couldn't really figure out
the idea because while capturing on on
e5 or on c5 is not really an idea the D
file is completely irrelevant because he
has no entry squares yeah but
nevertheless the position is about equal
um after rook c8 i'm setting up a very
simple threat the threat is c takes see
takes Bishop c4 and I'm winning upon um
I now expected to move d5 yeah with this
Bishop b6 rook c8 I'm actually almost
forcing this this move then I wanted to
go back and well of care of course here
the rooks look a bit silly but still he
probably has to do that and then we have
this typical yeah maneuver
better with the clothes center where I'm
going to play the night to age seven or
eight and then push a five to get play
on the kingside the Queen Cyrus is
completely closed note that in all these
lines the night on b3 is not the most
effective piece he really almost all of
the time wants to regroup it yeah to my
surprise he played now to move g3 which
yeah that was a bit stunts because well
I was a threat here to take wasn't
exactly am difficult to spot but he's
still ignored it and yeah it wasn't a
foreign sacrifice he simply gave it away
i don't know it was a lapse of
concentration or whatever this is just a
pawn and yeah after that black actually
should win the game it is a pretty
important pawn because pretty sure we
will trade bishops he tried to keep them
on the board but here he saw that it
doesn't really yeah and he can do that
he can't keep them on like here but what
I'm saying is the porn he has lost is
one thing but also there are there are
entries squares you know like rook here
rook c8 yeah I have a pawn and I have
fun play on the C file this is a very
very good position for black the other
idea that there is sometimes is the the
direct push with d5 yeah not at the
moment probably it's a bit early but
this opening of the center because he's
got some pawn moves on front of the king
and opening it up then in the pieces
towards the King might be an idea yeah
that's very nice he however hit Kiki
captured which is some which is a
mistake this makes it easier for black I
took with the Queen an interesting
moment I saw that F takes is also
interesting this opens up their file and
arguably this is even the better move
but I wasn't completely sure taking them
with the Queen it's not bad it just
keeps the structure sound
and I was a little bit this look
tempting to me I entering on age three
and I think it was a good decision it's
not another problem he played Queen f2
and yeah here we come to the first
moment where we can talk about
improvements I think up to this point i
played ok didn't do anything special he
gave me this pawn form pretty much
nothing and now it's time to to show him
good technical play um yeah for some
reason now I thought Queen h3 is a good
idea and to be honest I cannot really
explain why this some entered my mind
it's not a move that spoils all of my
advantage but it's really not to the
point my extra porn is on the queenside
and the most natural move in fact the
move that I originally wanted to play
and it was I wanted to play that and
then I thought how Queen esri is also
interesting I was kind of tempted to to
push the edge pawn & 9 h 5 and things
but this is this is really really
nonsense what I should do is just roots
III the move that I originally wanted to
play it puts the rook on this week and
square and prepares rook c8 yeah and it
makes sure that white never is going to
play a 4 ok the queen is on the night
anyway but it makes it them yeah
additionally different and this this is
also a possible idea entering even more
with the Queen on the queenside yeah
that's that's a fantastic position that
black with good technical play should
win this move is just losing time it's
not completely screwing everything up
but it loses time and I pretty much I
quickly quickly saw that that this was a
was a bad move rook t6 that's not
leading to much but then it's difficult
to why to give white some advice yeah
now rook e8 up late intending maybe
rookies e6 to exchange this rook
a for ya and this is something that I
really underestimated a4 a5 I was
thinking that this isn't so great
because I would always attack the night
and this night now is unprotected and I
always thought that I would enter on the
queenside then with my pieces and use
this looseness of his pieces but he
really has to play for if I've tried to
weaken my pawns and yeah I'm still much
better but I just lost time you know and
when Quincy area maybe rook c8 is better
just and then going back yeah just
acknowledging that this was not really
great and going and going back and I'm
going here and here I underestimated one
resource a five I thought that this
wasn't any good because of Quincy for
which is what I played but after the
capture and rook be one which is the
only move I suddenly saw that this isn't
so great actually yeah he's got a huge
pressure on the pawn and after the
capture which is what I originally
thought would be great he has a very
strong move that I overlooked I mean I
overlooked this when i played Quincy
eight but it was difficult to to do
something else by now um something like
let's say Bishop a7 is great yeah after
a form like wins but he has to move
Queen d2 and this is surprisingly strong
here I have problems then the essence of
this position is that my nights are
somewhat stuck here on the Kings idea
they look at the tone of protected
squares and they don't help to defend
the queenside may be here this is this
moment it's um as weird as it sounds
maybe he is the last moment where I can
keep some advantage I I now decided to
return the pawns which is probably not a
good too
decision I was what I saw is if I take
it on the tool which I didn't I probably
should have done that um I feared that I
will lose both pawns and if I able to to
keep them it will be difficult to make
any progress but a move like a six is
probably still giving me decent chance
is to convert this he will get one of
the pawns bag of course yeah if we look
at a position like that this kind of
position is probably going to happen and
this is what I had seen and I was really
in doubt that I can do something here he
will come with the king it's very
difficult to to make any make any
progress the engines also only give
black a very slight edge in this in this
position I still should have done that
it's a pawn and it's not apparent how he
gets it back he had some activity of
course but it's not like he's easily
getting the porn back and her husband
has a simple game I should have done
that really I went here my idea was the
following he took and i went to a forum
and here i thought okay well i'm trying
to play rook c8 see to using the week
second-ranked and if he takes a seven my
idea or my rationale was then this is
really leading to somewhat loose
position he still did it he just took
the pawn and here i really thought okay
i should have some kind of idea yeah
unfortunately it there is nothing there
is that seems to be nothing I thought
well unprotected unprotected this is
only covered by the Queen this is
unprotected I thought there should be
some way to use this this not very well
coordinated white forces but it's it's
obviously not possible one problem is
that if i play a move let's say like
Google you can play rugby aid and
general this is again unprotected and
somewhat yeah somewhat not well placed
but
by nights then also off on the on the on
the King side and I don't get to
activate them quickly now I tried h5
ultimately to try to push h4 and t just
pushed a plate atrium again this weakens
even more but there seems no way to
exploit it it looks a bit strange but
all this unprotected stuff it seems to
be impossible to exploit yeah look a
eight runs into Ruby eight so my idea
was still trying to win I played King f7
this is already slightly slightly risky
prepare through gate but it is it is
slightly slightly risky he went back
rooks e8 and just repeat to covering the
second rank yeah and I originally
thought well Queen a one isn't isn't
there something but he's got everything
protected I have no way to enter the
first Rangor or in any way do some kind
of invasion yeah so I went through gate
to just put it on b7 em em right in the
middle of my my camp yeah so what now
what now I decided to give this check
the computer is interestingly enough I
mean multiple engines is giving this
move I briefly thought about it but it
looked too crazy to me this is an
interesting way to play em I'm giving up
one of the nights which was looking at
protected squares anyway and this way
opening up the position this is probably
giving me enough compensation but I did
not really consider this
with any serious intent let's say I
briefly thought yeah I might I might be
able to take but couldn't really believe
it but it seems to be an interesting
interesting choice yeah I note that
again yeah I'm threatening this route
for real now and if he covers that I'm
invading this is what what the engines
are giving this is I this is an idea
it's it seems to be ok they they
evaluate the position is equal but this
was maybe the last idea to to really do
something can I went through the check
and played night to f8 the idea is to
get the night to e-cigs possibly to d4
win 96 yeah and here here we come to the
to the point where I'm overdoing things
of course I want to win and I really
must win this game I mean a draw is
simply too it's not enough so I am
thought what what to do now yeah the
problem is that I originally thought
okay maybe Ruby a dozen move here using
this pin I mean 96 loose it looks a bit
strange that he runs then he walks into
this pin but he has rook edge when it's
the wrong yeah this is a perpetual on my
queen so the move rook the eight assists
this is the best move I need to force
the draw now but I didn't want the
drawer so I went kingly eight back but
this now yeah okay Bishop g5 it's still
okay I can play rook 28 now again and we
have a draw but yeah I didn't want the
draw and I went back here with the night
yeah trying to kick the bishop back this
is a mistake simply and yeah if you if
you want you can treat it as a little
exercise white play and at least get
very very interesting chances
not completely sure I with winds to be
honest yeah what can Y do in this
position it didn't play it but what can
do i do yeah what can actually sacrifice
him and chat then give the check that's
a huge huge problem now how can I react
to that if I go here check he's got this
check and this is this is immediately
immediately over check checkmate nice
huh yeah it is very very dangerous I
have to go here actually which looks
crazy but it's the only move that is
somewhat interesting yeah yeah and yeah
i'm not sure if what if white can win
really it is it looks dangerous
obviously but can white winch and have a
look at this this looks crazy yeah but I
see no where near the engine also
doesn't see a win what why can do is
this yeah can always go for this with
three pawns against the night which is
from a practical point of view pretty
good because the pawns are just so much
more dangerous but I didn't see a win I
mean I really didn't 90 f7 was very
interesting though he didn't do that he
played Bishop e3 back pretty quickly as
well and yeah I went 96 and this is
actually a move that dust loose 96 now
does lose the game and I must admit that
I didn't have much time left I was
pretty much on the increment a little
bit more than that and I didn't really
consider repeating I mean I can repeat
yeah I can just do this and repeat and
what else is there i didn't really think
think very much I just went here and
when I saw that night f7 is an idea but
I didn't see it correctly he can now
take on f7 and this wings it really does
win cakes yes
the problem was that I saw this check
now the check this is much I saw and
here the problem is takes TS takes and I
thought okay this is this is ok because
the rook is saying but he has this
cactus little check and then e-cigs
faults with a check and I'm completely
completely lost yeah they can check here
then chera check out here yeah I mean
this is losing him I'm a I'm a big porn
down and have a bad King this is this is
going to end going to going to lose yeah
but she I think his mindset was too much
for draw him and he didn't really
consider this yet a little bit more time
than i had but yeah 9 f 7 that's it him
and he went night c4 just back route d8
Quincy one yeah he could have played
more actively with Quincy too I mean I
didn't really make huge progress here
this night but Quincy one you played it
out or safe after that I'm completely
out of the woods in terms of problems
but of course how am I ever going to win
this positioning it looks a bit strange
yeah with the CC far but there is
nothing yeah we should be too yeah there
are some some silly tricks yeah if he
does that he's losing all pieces but
it's ok it's easy yeah auntie em there
is really nothing going on I can I
cannot do much simply it had some back
some more moves and there was actually
one one interesting moment here in this
position in this position I should just
play something normally I like when
rupee three or something it is just a
draw but I wanted to win win win really
badly and I played f5 p.m. and this is I
mean it's probably not that terrible but
it is just not helping
much you can play route k6 m and now I
have to play King King f6 check check
back check and it's just just about a
draw if he takes 94 yeah I'm attacking
those two he could have tried that by
the way it's not not bad but he was just
inclined for for a draw and Jang he
didn't be gifted che get the check but
now he he just repeated it's quite funny
that that the computer and where it says
I was pretty pretty much amazed on the
computer actually gives this as a
playable move I was a bit surprised I
didn't consider that if I would have
seen it I thought maybe would have tried
it I already wanted to win this yeah
this is interesting with those two pawns
the computer actually says it leads to a
draw at the end which is kind of
difficult to believe but maybe maybe
yeah that was a very disappointing game
if your opponent hence your this pawn on
a silver played with this pretty weird
move g3 I mean yeah I've my last moves
yeah if you look at this Bishop is six
and rooks he hated pretty much says I'm
going to take your pawn on c4 mean this
is like telephoning your intentions very
clearly and he simply ignored it and not
winning after that deserve as a bit is a
bit embarrassing yeah okay and yeah this
meant that this was a half point that
that was clearly lacking yeah that I
really needed and I really had to win
the next game then this butch was played
on the same day in the evening and this
was played let me load it yeah this was
played against rafael rodriguez lopez
and a spanish i M rated about 2300 and
um yeah this is really a must-win now if
you with another draw
it becomes almost impossible to do any
anything like a norm you needed seven
out of nine in this tournament so you
can concede four drawers and I only
already had considered to weigh against
kumara fandom the the game that others
to show it so this is a must-win yeah
i'm playing a pretty quiet opening but
in my prep I saw that playing quiet it's
not a bad idea against him so I'm I'm
going for that it's all okay really he
plays this funny quadruple fianchetto
with b6 this is the line that I had on
the board the number of times and I
normally have good results with this
kind of position it is some very very
solid for black why does not have an
objective advantage but it's a kind of
position that I normally play well yeah
he didn't really know the theory here
well it was quite apparent he play
tonight h5 which is not terrible but
pretty clearly not the best move black
and just play d 6 97 and and do the
moves that he has to play anyway before
doing something like night age 5 which
essentially it just loses time I went
back he takes and he goes back to Essex
Zoe considered a couple of moves here
are some time for a trade that I welcome
yeah white now has a slight advantage
out of the opening and all this was was
pretty normal an interesting moment is
here and maybe I'm I'm not really
hitting the right timing in this in this
position um and now I know went from 95
this is a case where I'm completely did
not take into account his reply I just
thought okay the night has to go there
anyway and i'm playing 94 next in
typical this is a typical scenario form
this english opening maroc see bind type
of positions you put the night on
and it's very annoying there for black
to play around and very often they have
to take it but here is a situation where
the capture from a strategic point of
view is simply terrible he played it
anyway and it's not so terrible as
thought because of some concrete reasons
I simply didn't look at the move because
as mentioned strategically it's it's
just just very bad but as mentioned for
concrete reason it is it is playable
what I did not really to take into
account is the direct attack on the pawn
the thing is if I now just let's say
theoretically speaking could play 90
form for knight c6 this is what i meant
yeah why this is a strategically risky
decision he has this is six weakness and
if i get the knight to c6 it will be
very very very unpleasant for him the
problem is that after the direct move
Knight f6 d500 vApp play now 94 he can
really take that no there is there is no
no trickery here he's attacking the
night I have no way to to exploit this
this thing this means i cannot play 94
and the pawn is hanging so the only move
left is the move Knight to you want and
this is of course not really well the
night wants to go yeah you want to go to
d4 and then to c6 ultimately and not
drop back to be one this is the only
reason why this is even halfway playable
for black that my knight takes them such
as such a long time to get to the square
white is still somewhat better but it's
not as catastrophic as a thought when
I'm pretty much discarded the capture on
the fire firm without looking at it
really he went rook c8 the ideas
obviously rook to see Five may be
putting more pressure on the porn yeah I
went nite c2 yeah this is the route
anyway I want to go buy a one of those
squares
from be three yeah I want to go to see
six yeah he went rogue c5 began a move I
did not really consider because I
thought Alice's this is useful for me
anyway but okay here after whoopsie
seven I am played this is interesting I
played b5 it was also interesting to
play the move 94 I couldn't I couldn't
really decide what to do it it both
looks looks quite nice um b5 is
strengthening this idea of night
difference is six but it concedes a c5
square it's a matter of concrete
consideration maybe 94 is more precise
but I mean my move is not really bad he
went group c 5 24 and then again i'm
looking to to do this you went eat six
yeah again I move I move I did not
really consider but it is the relatively
best one in the position he has to do
something if I'm if I'm allowed to play
Knight d4 c6 this is just too bad the
night coming there so he opened up I
thought that it would weaken the central
position far too much share also this
kind of thing but it seems to be ok as
weird as it looks but it seems to be ok
Knight takes before by the way it was an
interesting move that is quite quite
quite quite yet but not so bad after
Ruby one f5 it looks strange to let this
pawned it but there seems to be no
refutation yeah he didn't do that he
just recaptured with the pawn and I went
94 still looking at this and looking at
this yes those big bones on d6 andy sixx
yeah he went Queenie 72 to cover that
and I played queen bee three accusing
the pressure on the wiki 6 porn yeah 25
yeah now is an interesting moment and
here I'm maybe making I'm not
it really maybe it's a mistake I don't
know I made one mistake definitely
because I am pretty much a tube t5 now
quite quickly I should have at least
considered be five a little bit it's an
interesting move it has some negative
sites because it closes the center in a
situation where black is actually shaky
there but on the other hand that gives
me a very nice night on deform and
sometimes ideas to attack the ecig spawn
with Bishop a tree the problem seems to
be 94 were just kind of unclear but I
did not really consider he five
seriously and I should have looked at it
yeah okay taking on d5 is not bad
however it is in a way the more logical
move takes takes gallant here he should
take with the pawn this is what i read
what i expected the pawn on d5 is much
easier to defend than the pony six but
we took with the with the night and now
after luke t 2 i'm definitely better
rooked it to us is intending to play
this rook to e1 and to increase the
pressure here on only six it's a very
very nice position for wide and you went
Queen f7 wiki 197 has to protect you six
and a form they are covering be five so
that I'm able to move my night he went
group t5 and now Queen III up to this
point I'm pretty pretty okay with my
player I'm better to some extent I
wasn't completely sure during the game
how much better I am if you want the
computer eval 0.7 something like that is
what stockfish and Houdini give when
rook t8 and night f3 okay I'm trading
one pair of roofs but still what remains
is the better structure black has one
two three Pawn islands I only have two I
have the better bone structure and I
have chances to use the night effective
this is one route this is the other
route and the other is putting the night
only form after 97 it was interesting by
the way I also can go to f3 I couldn't
really decide it it's both interesting
if you go to f3e 5 is a tempting square
anyway and c6 as well so and I didn't
really know I went 94 to emphasize this
again plate here and I went Queen g5
Quincy one is maybe a bit better but
it's not a huge difference the one
problem comes here after rookie evade
here I'm making a mistake I mean okay I
didn't have much time but still the next
move is kind of his kind of pointless
really um yeah I went um I went Queenie
7 what I should do is Quincy form having
a look at this pawn and then marching up
the H porn well this is this is what I
what I should do but i didn't i didn't
play that why actually was a drug f2 it
irritated me but this is not a myth yeah
Quinn gvoice is just better and after
this he has to look booth and then I had
to go to a 2 a 3 yeah I don't know
Quincy for was just better when King g7
h4 white is still somewhat better but
his active Queen on d4 helps them a
little bit aged six key to all this is
kind of kind of normal yeah now I had
this opportunity to play age five and it
is strictly to defend it is tricky to
offend roguelike here now went Queen d5
and I went now / queen e 2 2g for this
is a this is an idea to put more more
pressure on him yeah it's um it's not
easy for black to defend went here
to form and night if I this is just
about holding em takes and rube d6 this
is maybe not the most precise move it's
um maybe Queenie sixes better trying to
try to hold this position I'm always
better due to the bone structure but it
is there is very little firepower left
yeah probably we will get some kind of
endgame a heavy piece endgame it's not
easy to to win after rook t6 however I'm
getting something very very tangible
King g1 getting out of this pin takes
here and now 95 yeah and here this is a
very nice position now he took with the
with the rook and here I'm here I'm
making a mistake after Luke g5 I am
didn't really consider Queenie to hear
this is this is the better move Queen
before look tempting because going to e7
but Queenie to was better simply because
of the idea to play rook t1 and getting
a look the rook on the open file after
that he has the best big problems to
defend if he plays this attending rook
g3 I have Queen f3 yeah after Queenie
too he has very serious problems to
defend the position it's um it's very
difficult he's also tied to this pawn
and I mean I don't know what he should
play a maybe a king move I'm gonna look
him go through I going with them and
then this is a very nice position his
ruckus is somewhat off side I have
Queenie for Brooke t7 that's very very
nice it's much better than my queen e7
queen before move with the idea to play
27 here he had Queen f3 and this post
some problems still still after queena
three I can get a very very big
advantage
but I failed to see that as well I
played Queenie for at the end he's
threatening Rocky III of course yeah
with the draw with a perpetual what I
could have done is I could have
countless check check and here use this
square an idea that i really did not see
at all this is this is much better the
queen is check check check now ready to
help and I'm Kennex I can escape here if
we look at this again why is this so
strong yeah what is what is the smooth
now his Queen as attacked if he trades
this is going to going to lead to a very
difficult endgame this this is just one
line check yet I have serious winning
chances of course it's not like an easy
win but I have happening chances yeah
it's better than Queenie form what can I
say here he took him and went king f6
and if you watched my video yesterday I
was referring to an end game but that I
was not sure about this end game is
coming up now him this rook endgame um I
must say that this was this tournament
was played with 90 minutes per game and
30 second increment and around here um
we both were down to like two minutes or
so and played on the increment so it is
basically a rapid kamia cannot expect to
perfection in this kind of time control
I think we played it decently up to one
point yeah and it's clear that I'm
getting this warning i'm always getting
this pawn on a seven um but the round
here check look at this is booko king of
free was a bit strange this move but it
still it's to the draw it seems look f6
and here he's playing up playing a
strange move
rook h8 is just much better here after
which I have to return otherwise I'm
losing just losing this bond simply oh
sorry here efore first yeah okay the
check is better but he went to a 8
trying to get to the a four point and
this is a this is an interesting moment
here where I've analyzed this a little
bit in the game this was the last spot
where spent like a minute or two minutes
and I couldn't really decide what to do
um the two candidate moves on from me at
least it was playing rook b6 and g4 in
whatever order or bring the King up and
I ultimately decided to bring the King
up it is very difficult to come to a
conclusion but I should have played a G
form this was more interesting this is
the this is the line g-form Luke a form
look b6 this is this position we form g5
and I'm still not one hundred percent
sure about this end game and I looked at
it a little bit with the computer and it
seems to be a draw but I'm not one
hundred percent percent sure it's a kind
of a strange endgame yeah because my my
two pawns are somewhat alone and the
king is not supporting them in any way
and this is also why I didn't play like
that it seemed a bit odd to me um
especially if you look at this I have to
have to go back here to to get any kind
of probably 2h to even and I think this
is a drawn I looked and looked a little
bit but I couldn't really come come to
to a successful conclusion there let's
let's have a look what was my main line
here g5 rook a [ __ ] a 4g 6 Rooke a7
this is what what black should do yeah
and now let's say rook a 6
group g7 and I don't really see how to
make progress here rookie 6 for example
King f5 Luke c6 back in keeney five I I
don't see how to do to get anywhere here
maybe you find a win if you if you have
time on your hands and I interested in
this route game game I'm not sure that
the comp at some time after you give it
some time says says equal but i'm not
sure i'm really not totally sure i went
Kings you for this is this is a mistake
because it makes things easier but ok
this is a kind of a gut feeling the same
yeah we get got to this point and now
the e porn is just too strong I have no
winning chances here I when g5 III yeah
and now I have to make sure that I'm not
not losing and play rookie 6 check check
King up e 2 yeah and now have to be a
little bit cautious if you go g6 and
this is this is probably a draw yeah
this is probably still a draw i can i
can take this and then still hold a draw
but it's easier to just take here and
then g6 and here we agree to a draw I'm
just promoting the Jeep on and he has to
give up his recurrent and then we have
bad Kings so this was the second draw on
that fatal fatal day and a bit
disappointing of course because I had
two very had nice positions it's at some
points yeah like here here i was quite
confident that i should be able to win
this but Queen Queen before and and the
next
couple of moves layers simply weren't
precise enough so yeah he fought well to
to to gain this draw but this basically
meant then I was condemned to to win the
rest of my games almost there and well
it's very difficult is the left to to
2500 grandmasters to play and a couple
of young feeder master so very difficult
after this draw to do something in this
tournament yeah and this is actually
where the ugly the ugly part of meta
element starts and this is covered in
round 3 of this in part 3 of this little
serious and which will be probably
released them tomorrow okay well thanks
for watching